thank you welcome and thank you for
coming to our professional conference
today regarding The Disappearance of
Leah Croucher and the subsequent murder
investigation
I cannot even begin to imagine what it
is like for Leah's parents and family
for three years and eight months not
knowing what has happened to their
daughter and loved one
all of the investigation team who are
working on this case are dedicated to
finding the truth for Leah's family
I want to recap on the developments this
week since Monday the 10th of October
and provide a number of updates in
relation to our investigation which as
I'm sure you can appreciate is complex
and fast moving
on Monday at about 6 30 p.m police were
contacted with information about a
property in locksmere Drive first and
Milton Keynes
we promptly attended and a number of
items were located inside the property
these items included a rucksack and
personal possessions belonging to Leah
who was reported missing on the 15th of
February 2019.
sadly
human remains were also found inside the
property close to the rucksack
as a result of our findings Thames
Valley police changed its investigation
from a missing person investigation to a
murder investigation
as I stated the investigation is moving
at PACE and as such I can share with you
some further updates today
but at the very outset of our
investigation Into The Disappearance of
Leah we assigned this case our most
experienced and capable team of
detectives led by a senior investigating
officer
this attests to our determination to
find Leah
thereafter we immediately and salary
followed every reasonable line of
inquiry we committed hundreds of
officers and staff to the search for
Leah reviewing 1 200 hours of CCTV
conducting more than 4 000 house to
house inquiries searching Lakes open
land and Woodland
we have sustained and significant media
appeals and offered several public
rewards for information
but sadly the call from the member of
the public that we received on Monday
this week was the first occasion that
information was made available to enable
the investigation team to provide any
link between that address in lochbear
drive and Leah
prior to this in the course of visiting
those 4 000 properties I can confirm
that number two locksmere Drive was
visited on at least two occasions
however there was no response at the
house
therefore we dropped a leaflet through
the letterbox requesting a callback if
the occupant of the property had any
information
in addition to the house to house
inquiries we also visited the property
to scope what CCTV may be available in
the area
since we were alerted to this property
on Monday evening
we have established that the property is
owned by someone who lives overseas and
rarely visits the United Kingdom
it is now known that the owner was not
in the UK at the time Leah was reported
missing and the house was unoccupied
when police attended on these inquiries
today
I'm able to confirm that we have
nominated a suspect in this case
his name is Neil Maxwell
however
Maxwell was found dead on the 20th of
April
2019 having taken his own life
it is unusual to name a suspect
but we have also learned this week that
during the time when Leah went missing
and whilst the owner of the property was
not in the UK
Maxwell was the only person to have keys
to that property
Maxwell had been employed by the
homeowner to carry out some Property
Maintenance at the house
we now know that Maxwell had keys to
this property from November 2018.
whilst Maxwell has been nominated as a
suspect this does not mean he is guilty
of any offense
we will keep an open mind and our
detailed investigation will seek to
gather sufficient evidence to establish
the truth
this may or may not implicate or
exonerate Maxwell or any other persons
from the investigation
Maxwell has previous convictions for
sexual offenses against women and girls
and was wanted in connection with a
sexual assault in Newport pagnell in
November 2018.
the sexual assault was reported to
bedfordshire police on the 29th of
November 2018 and the case was
transferred to Thames Valley police on
the same day
we first attempted to arrest Maxwell in
connection with the sexual assault the
following day 30th of November 2018 at
an address in central Milton Keynes but
Maxwell was not present
during this time
we established that Maxwell was at an
unknown location in Scotland at one
point but further arrest attempts were
continually made throughout the UK at
various different addresses
Maxwell knew he was wanted in connection
with the sexual assault and was
traveling across the UK and making
concerted efforts to pervade the rest
including using false names and changing
his mobile phone and vehicles
he is highly likely to have known that
he would be returning to prison if he
was arrested and convicted
Thames Valley police shed Maxwell's name
with other police forces on the police
national computer in December 2018.
we also published a wanted public wanted
appeal to find Maxwell on the 4th of
April 2019 but Maxwell was subsequently
found dead on the 20th of April 2019
having taken his own life
a significant number of inquiries were
made nationally to locate Maxwell and
these included 18 separate arrest
attempts
and in April 2019 when we published our
wanted appeal regarding Maxwell in
connection with the sexual assault in
Newport pagnell and during our entire
investigation to find Leah
there has been no direct link between
Maxwell and Leah until this week when we
were called about the property in loxby
Drive
if Maxwell was alive today we would be
seeking his arrest in connection with
this investigation so he could be
interviewed under caution to provide his
account
as such today I'm appealing to anybody
who had contact with Maxwell
between November 2018
and his death in April 2019 or anybody
else who has information that might help
our inquiry to contact Thames Valley
police
you can do this by contact by visiting
our website or by calling 101 quoting
operation Innsbrook that's Operation
Innsbrook
the property in loxbury Drive is a
complex and challenging scene
and I want to let local residents know
that it could be a number of weeks
before we are able to conclude our
forensic examinations
therefore we expect this investigation
to be protracted but we will update the
public and the media as we have done
when we can during our investigation
the outpouring of emotion and support to
Leah's family from the community
has been overwhelming
Leah's family continue to be supported
by our specially trained officers
and our thoughts are and always will be
with them
before I take questions
the senior investigation officer visited
Leah's parents and family this morning
and fully briefed them on everything I
have just told you
they know of this press conference and
they have specifically asked me to read
the following
we would like to take this opportunity
to thank Thames Valley police
for all their efforts over the last
three years and eight months
we believe that they could not have done
anything differently they have always
approached every conversation with
dignity and compassion
as a family
we ask that everyone
respects our privacy
as well as our immediate family
are what is
one of the most difficult times of Our
Lives
happy for Ian to take a limited number
of questions he's got a limited amount
of time before he does have to get back
to the office and work on the
investigation it would be useful if you
can say your name and where you're from
and keep your questions succinct if
possible
um yeah it's John from beauty to the
heath have you been able to establish
establish why Neil Maxwell had keys to
the property and is there any indication
at this stage whether near Newton prior
to know again
on your first point he had keys to the
property because he was commissioned to
do some Property Maintenance work at the
address on behalf of the owner who lives
outside of the United Kingdom
in terms of your second Point there's
nothing just now that I can firmly
establish any link between Leah and
Maxwell prior to the information that we
received this week
of course there's an active
investigation and we keep an open mind
and that will be subject to our
inquiries as we go forward
owner
was unaware of Neil Maxwell's previous
and was unaware that he was on the run
and never appeals out at the time
because I'm sure he contacted him and
can you tell us a little bit more about
the tip-off
that person on again making an
assumption here you might go to
pass it away but must have known me on
Maxwell and had they claimed the 25th
so in terms of the owner we are in
contact with the owner there is no
information I have currently that
suggests they knew of the background of
Maxwell but that will be subject to an
ongoing investigation
uh you mentioned the reward that's not
something that's been asked about any
further at this stage but you would
appreciate we're right at the early
stages here of our inquiry
so the person that informed us on Monday
had been commissioned um separately from
the owner overseas to carry out some
work at that address
it's probably appropriate for me to say
that due to covid the the owner had
rarely been in the UK during that period
of time
so often it seems commissioned some work
to be done at the address
there is there is nothing that I know
just now subject to the ongoing
investigation that links the person
giving us information on Monday to
Maxwell
can you tell us about who kind of
provides you with that information
so that person was doing some work at
the address for the UK owner and they
informed us some concerns at the
property and that led to a call into
police and further investigations by us
ing what else will you be looking for do
we know anything else about this address
previously for example so here we've got
a situation where it's very challenging
and complex investigation we need to
work through the scene forensically to
fully understand everything that might
have happened in that address to help
the investigation move forward that's
why it might take some time
and what else are you looking for at
this stage is there anything that you
can tell us you're particularly aiming
to find for example I'm sure you
appreciate for operational reasons I
can't go into the the active
investigation song
would you have expected officers to have
gone back from
the properties of occasions so the house
house inquires we did as part of the
missing person investigation were
extensions as I said we visited 4 000
properties during that time a number of
people
um a number of people were in and
present when we were there we've
subsequently found during our
investigation that a number of houses
weren't occupied at that time some
people wouldn't have wanted perhaps to
to answer the door so we do go back
um several times as we did here and we
also do leave a leaflet for people to
contact us if they've got any
information
um sadly at that address there was no
one there to be able to respond to that
it's a bit about the human
so do we know how long they were there
for and whereabouts they were found
so of course we've got an ongoing
investigation so we will need to try and
establish some of those facts
um but I will uh reveal today that the
uh the rucksack containing uh Leah's
possessions and the human remains were
found in the loft
and that is what is making this so
complex and challenging for us to be
able to work through
foreign
on your first point the home office
post-mortem is taking place as we speak
um identification will take place as
soon as we are able to do that uh as
well
this inquiry was always extremely
challenging if we go back to buzzerkat
Lane and the CCTV at lh16 on the 15th of
February there were no further lines of
inquiry that helped us much further from
there so of course
Leah's route to work has always been
subject to intense scrutiny throughout
our investigation
the four thousand properties visit
visited the CCTV that we're able to
obtain has been viewed
now at this stage of course it's an
active line of arm inquiry did Leah
walked past that house and some sort of
action took place and that's exactly
what the investigation team are going to
try and establish
it that's impossible for me to answer
this stage we will need to we'll need to
await the results of the home office at
postmortem and take forward the
investigation
we have
that's not something I'm going to
discuss here that's an operational
matter for the investigation as we as we
work through and understand exactly what
that house contains and as I've said the
search is going to take some time
of the property has um come back to the
visit maybe in the months after latest
appearance I'll be writing this evening
that she was potentially in that
property
it's really difficult to answer at this
stage in in all honesty we need to
better understand the timeline we're in
contact with the the owner from overseas
but
um it is possible that people have
stayed at that property in the situation
you describe but we need to firm that up
uh yeah go ahead
um is there any indication at all that
that's an active part of the
investigation and with the home office
post-mortem ongoing as we speak uh we
will need to progress that in due course
this this investigation uh in my
experience is one of the largest missing
person investigations I've ever been
aware of the concerted media
coverage has of course affected all of
the residents of of the local area and
wider Milton Keynes and I suspect uh
much more widely beyond what we've tried
to do is keep people up to date with the
investigation as much as we possibly can
trying to be open and explaining what
the situation is we don't want to
increase fear unnecessarily we want to
keep people informed of what we're doing
and why we're doing it
um we uh we've been really active in the
area around first and since this week we
would urge anybody who's got any
concerns you know to reach out and to
speak to somebody if they're worried
about that about any of this which we
completely understand as well
where he was you have no indication
we don't know he was staying at that
property but we were actively seeking to
arrest him we knew he was wanted he knew
he was wanted we were making numerous
the best attempts for him and as I
described he was making active steps to
evade us using a false name changing his
phone changing his vehicle Etc I suspect
strongly that he knew he was going to go
back to prison if found and I think
that's why it was proving so difficult
to be able to locate him at what and
it's also why we would be sharing
information with the police national
computer and also taking the the step
that we took to name him in the public
eye as well
include shortly yeah
so um obviously it you're focusing on
art
if you can tell
so Maxwell today has been nominated as a
suspect there are no other suspects
currently nominated
I hope that reassures the local
community and I hope people can
understand how challenging and difficult
this is for the investigation team to
work through
we're going to do that in the the most
diligent manner that we possibly can and
we will keep the public up to date and I
know that all of our offices and staff
who are working extremely hard on this
investigation are absolutely committed
to establishing the truth
last one in the middle uh news agency
are you looking at the possibility that
Mia was walking around
the investigation will look at all
possibilities we'll reassess of course
the information that we now know and
there's a full investigation team led by
our head of major crime that is leading
the investigation
everyone's happy with that thank you
very much
mailing list we have now email
a statement and this picture